foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
our top story the violence must stop the
plea from the United Nations as the
Palestinian city of Janine Burns
Hamas claims responsibility for a car
running attack in Tel Aviv tonight
Israeli forces began to withdraw from
the occupied West Bank people we've
spoken through here say they will
continue to defend the city and you can
see it in evidence there and the
Israelis say they will come back here if
they need to
also tonight A man is
a man is there and her two daughters by
setting their flat alight then ignoring
their screams
former brexit party leader Nigel farage
denies reports he has two little funds
after his private Bank closed his
account Plus
the Ferocious fires caused by faulty
e-bike batteries with investigators
calling for more regulation
we hear from the mayor trapped for five
days with no food or water after taking
this shortcut home
and we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages that's coming up
in our press preview from 10 30.
[Music]
hello there good evening Israeli forces
began withdrawing from the Palestinian
city of Janine this evening after the
biggest military operation for two
decades today the United Nations pleaded
for the violence to end and revealed
that three children were among the 11
people killed during two days of raids
and airstrikes but then another attack
was captured on CCTV a young man claimed
as a Hamas militant drove his car
towards a restaurant in Tel Aviv then
carried out a stabbing attack injuring
nine people well the week began with
drone bombings then a ground incursion
into the densely populated refugee camp
in the northern West Bank our Middle
East correspondent Alistair bunkel
traveled to Janine a warning his report
shows the moment of a retaliatory attack
in Israel and the immediate aftermath
the drive into Janine is an obstacle
course around barricades in the road and
burning tires
the Israeli military has set up
checkpoints on the outskirts stopping
everyone as they go in and out
inside there are very few people on the
streets all the shops have closed and
families are Sheltering in their homes
the only people were young men who say
they'll keep fighting the Israelis until
they leave
it's not normal 48 hours and the boys
are still in the camp facing airstrikes
people are fleeing their homes they are
destroying the camp we don't know what
is the murders are and people are still
under durable and the Jets are firing
and hear the drones overheads
the constant sound of Israeli drones
overhead is only broken by ambulance
sirens as they rush to reach the wounded
Columns of heavily armored Israeli
military vehicles Patrol the center of
Janine there are more than a thousand
soldiers involved in this operation
video released by the Israeli military
shows weapons and explosives they've
seized they say they found an
underground stockpile dug beneath a
mosque the people we've spoken to here
say they will continue to defend the
city I mean you can see it in evidence
there and the Israelis say they will
come back here if they need to
in the middle of the night thousands of
Palestinians fled the refugee camp in
the city for safety elsewhere many with
their hands in the air some waving White
Flags
the United Nations says it urgently
needs to get food water and Medicine
into the City and the Red Cross said the
situation is getting worse with each
passing minute
on Tuesday afternoon in Tel Aviv a car
drove into people injuring 10. Israel
said it was a terror attack
this CCTV shows the attacker stabbing
people on the street he was shot dead
Hamas have claimed responsibility and
said it was in retaliation for Janine
back in Janine the fighting continued
through the afternoon but on Tuesday
evening Israeli forces started to
withdraw from the city
the operation which was the biggest in
the West Bank for almost 20 years
appears to be over at least for now
is back in Jerusalem for us this evening
so Alistair those indications that
Israeli troops are withdrawing but not
without cost there
no this was an operation that was
expected to last for many many days when
it was originally carried out but about
48 hours almost exactly since that first
drone strike in Janine the Israeli
military is now leaving the city we
understand that in their efforts to try
and extract themselves from the city
they have had to carry out more
airstrikes uh but uh from what we
understand they are very much leaving
the city and the operation is over they
feel that they have achieved the
objectives they wanted to achieve and
for now at least as I said in my report
that operation is over the problem is is
they leave a city where we were today
where you know this has been going on
for many many years this is not the
first time by any stretch to the Israeli
military has been engineered they go in
there very regularly and every time it
incentivizes many of those in the city
to fight back against Israel and so it
is very very hard to see how this
operational though it might bring some
sort of short-term temporary piece uh to
what is happening here in in Israel and
the West Bank one of the bloodiest years
of the Year here in the long term I
don't think that will achieve its
objectives and the Israeli military
whilst they would have captured weapon
friends they would gather love
intelligence they'll have arrested many
people in the course of the last 40 of
hours you know the the problem the the
issue the the resentment the anger
between the two sides nothing has
changed there
Alistair in Jerusalem thank you
he set their home a light then he
ignored their screams today a 31 year
old man was found guilty of murdering a
mother and her two young daughters by
pouring petrol through their letterbox
while they slept
fatimatahidera's husband remembered his
wife as an incredible mother and his
daughters Fatima and Nema as two angels
who deserved a beautiful childhood and a
full life Becky Johnson has this report
one-year-old Nema and her three-year-old
sister Fatima were murdered as they
slept they were at home with their
mother fatimata haidara when their
next-door neighbor set fire to their
flat in Nottingham
it was the early hours of the morning
firefighters tried to rescue the family
inside but the girls couldn't be saved
their mother had died days later in
hospital
as Jamie Barrow was convicted of their
murders their father and husband spoke
about the loss of his children and his
wife
if love and compassion could make a
person Immortal she would have lived
forever she was most incredible mother
to Fatima and Naima
two angels who deserve a very beautiful
childhood
and a full life
at this point in time I'm going to place
you under arrest for murder times two
okay Barrow was arrested after telling
officers he was going to hand himself in
he admitted pouring petrol through the
family's letterbox and setting it a
light but tried to claim that he didn't
know they were in
he denied the killings with deliberate
thankfully the investigation team was
able to provide overwhelming evidence
that this tragic event was indeed murder
we saw through his lies and thankfully
so did the jewelry
Barrow had been drinking on the night of
the fire he bought more beer than headed
home
moments after the fire took hold he
calmly walked away returning a short
time later to ask police how bad it was
even smiling at offices as he answered
their questions he later rang police to
ask when he could get back into his flat
hello my name's Jamie I live on the
farewell close at number 19. and whether
next to where the fire was earlier this
morning yeah yeah and this one's really
doing any update on whether I'm alive I
can prostitute my prophecy or not
prosecutors say his motive for the
murders may never be known he has a
personality disorder and says he's lit
fires before to release stress claiming
it mesmerizes him but another theory is
that he was annoyed about rubbish bags
that have been left in an alley
abubakar drama was in America at the
time of the fire his wife and daughters
were applying for visas to join him
their dream of a new life together
Shattered by a neighbor who still
refuses to explain why he murdered them
Becky Johnson's Sky News Nottingham
yesterday it was the supermarkets who
stood accused of profiteering during a
cost of living crisis this morning a
similar charge was leveled at the four
big High Street banks for failing to
pass on Rising interest rates to Savers
our business correspondent Paul Kelsey
can explain more
the big banks have been summoned because
Regulators are concerned they're
short-changing Savers and we can see the
problem here the purple line is the Bank
of England base rate up from almost zero
to five percent in 18 months that's seen
mortgage rates the Orange Line bolt up
two this is the two-year fixed rate
almost six point five percent now five
year fixes have just gone over six
percent as well but savings down here in
green have dawdled by comparison an
average rate of just above 2.4 for
instant access accounts so this Gap is
an opportunity for banks to profit from
Savers and borrowers landlord David
France is both
where the interest rates going up we're
getting hurt with the money that we
borrow
and the money that's in the bank we're
not getting enough interest and
certainly not the uh appropriate
interest which we feel we should be
getting based on the rates going up on
our on our debt for now rate rise is a
benefiting Savers more than they're
costing mortgage holders the orange line
here is the increase in savings income
in the last 18 months that's nudging 25
billion extra in accounts but the extra
cost of mortgages is about half that
around 13 billion pounds and that's
because increased savings rates are felt
instantly while your mortgage payment
depends on your deal and almost 9 out of
10 mortgages are now fixed rates almost
60 percent of homeowners have five-year
fixes that's the red here a quarter the
blue have up to two years left which
leaves just 12 percent the portion in
green on floating rates which are
exposed immediately to rate Rises now
that's a huge change from seven years
ago when almost half of us had mortgage
rates that were variable and this
matters because it's now taking longer
for interest rates to squeeze the
economy and thus bring down inflation
the Prime Minister agrees that's a
problem
you're right about the transmission
mechanism being perhaps slower when it
comes to mortgages than it has been in
the past because of the hundreds of
people to have at least short-term fixed
rate mortgages now but that's something
that the bank take into account in their
modeling all of this will change in the
next 18 months around 1.7 million fixed
rate deals will expire next year leaving
households paying an extra 2 900 pounds
on average that's a wave of financial
pain that increased saving is unlikely
to offset
Paul Kelso there now from The High
Street to a more Boutique financial
institution the private bank Coots is
locked in a public rail with the former
brexit party leader Nigel farage over a
decision to close his account this
evening Mr farage denied reports that he
had too little funds and insisted he was
being targeted because of his political
views his Murray Aurora
a man known for his divisive political
views Nigel farage is back in the
headlines
but this time it's his finances that
have got people talking
the former ukip leader has claimed the
exclusive Bank Coots has closed his
account due to his political status as a
politically exposed person that is now
nine other banks that have refused me
they're telling the Press I don't meet
their wealth threshold well they've
never mentioned that before in the
previous 10 years the worst of a story
is they denied to me on the phone on
Friday that I was a pep a politically
exposed person that's the reason nobody
else will have me and Coots are frankly
being very very dishonest
Sky News contacted Coots for comment and
they directed us to their website which
reads clients are required to maintain
at least one million pounds in
Investments or borrowing mortgage or 3
million pounds in savings
Coots also explains it takes into
account commercial viability legal or
regulatory requirements and reputation
claiming the bank's actions are
politically motivated farage has failed
to deny that he has too few funds in his
account to remain eligible at a time
when Banks and the financial sector are
already in the firing line over
allegations of profiteering regarding
interest rates questions around whether
banks are targeting their clients
because of their political views will do
nothing to enamor the sector to the
public
Rishi sunak and Nigel farage have not
been the most obvious political
bedfellows but today the Prime Minister
weighed into the debate the chancellor
has been very clear about this and
spoken to The Regulators obviously we
have to respect people's right to free
speech and that should not be an excuse
to close anyone's account and that's not
what we would expect
he's known for his often controversial
views but he claims he's now being
targeted for them Mari Aurora Sky News
tomorrow the NHS marks its 75th
anniversary with a special service at
Westminster Abbey but the data shows
that with record waiting lists and staff
shortages there is little for patients
to celebrate exclusive analysis for Sky
News shares Health inequalities are
getting wider while patients face a
postcode Lottery to access care well all
but two of the 50 most deprived
neighborhoods in England are in the
north and of those just over half are in
the Northwest concentrated in cities
like Manchester and Liverpool where some
of the starkist differences in health
outcomes can be seen the world has the
biggest proportion of preventable deaths
under 75 than any other local Authority
in England a health correspondent Ashish
Joshi reports now from birkenhead which
has one of the lowest life expectancies
in the country
only got an urgent call after this
morning so I can get the GP to give you
a call back can I just have a brief
reason for the calls it's just after
eight in the morning and the Scramble
for a doctor's appointment is well
underway we've had our phones open for
about an hour we've already got almost
40 calls booked already Dr lakshman Arya
Raj is triaging his patience
hello hi uh Joe how can I help you today
he spots one he's worried about and
wants her to come in immediately what
we'll try and do is to squeeze you in
and get a blood test done while you're
here yes okay
Dr Arya Rogers Clinic is in birkenhead
in the Wirral one of the most deprived
communities in the country here the m53
is a dividing line if you live on the
right of the motorway heading north you
can expect to die younger and if you
live on the left the Wirral is one of
the most divided areas in the country
both in terms of economic deprivation
and of course Health outcomes and it's
here we find the biggest Gap in
preventable deaths for any local
Authority in England
women here have the sixth lowest life
expectancy at just over 74 years and for
men it's worse the third lowest life
expectancy at around 67. I think the
biggest problem is money really
um
I think there needs to be more more
employment from the point of view of
getting people into work the more can be
done with housing we see houses housing
that's boarded up
which if the bit of money was spent we
could do it up for people who are
homeless or need accommodation we've had
a temperature for a few days and you've
been feeling tired for a few weeks now
Health inequalities are greater here in
the Northwest than anywhere else in
England you can probably throw a cricket
ball from uh from significant wealth to
abject poverty in this area we need more
resources in our health system and I
would sort of put a plea for if and when
those resources come that we prioritize
areas such as these where I think that
extra resource can make the most
difference
the NHS says lessons have been learned
from the pandemic about connecting with
communities we noticed that many people
from some of our social economically
deprived communities or people from some
of our ethnic minority communities
seemed to struggle with confidence to
come forward good to engage with public
services you're here to see
um Susan Lockwood she's got some pain in
her back Dr Arya Rogers patients needs
are changing there are more care home
visits reflecting an aging population
with complex health issues hello Mandy
was telling me that you've had a bit of
a pain lately it's arthritis it's just
getting worse and worse and to be honest
it is starting to spread try a bit of
the soup this with widening Health
inequalities will test the NHS as it
faces up to its next 75 years Ashish
Joshi Sky News in the world
the Metropolitan Police has reopened an
investigation into potential covid
breaches during a party at conservative
party headquarters in December 2020 tier
2 restrictions were in place at the time
winning no social mixing outside
households or social or support bubbles
a Tory birthday gathering in Parliament
the same month for the wife of
privileges Committee Member sir Bennett
Jenkin is also being reinvestigated it's
reported that he attended the event
which was cited by Boris Johnson in a
statement accusing sir Bernard of
monstrous hypocrisy
times water has been fined 3.3 million
pounds after admitting to accidentally
pumping undiluted sewage into rivers
near Gatwick Airport in 2017. The Firm
admitted guilt in all of the four
charges it faced Thames water has been
sanctioned several times in recent years
for missing targets and pollution
incidents last week's County's reported
the government was considering
temporarily taking the company into
public ownership because of its debt
load
the Captain Tom Moore Foundation says it
stopped taking donations or making
payments as an investigation into its
finances continues the charity
commission is looking into concerns
about the Charities management by the
family of the late veteran who raised
Millions for the NHS it comes as
planning bosses ordered an unauthorized
building at the bedfordshire home of
Captain Tom's daughter to be demolished
Southern Crown Court in London has heard
that Kevin Spacey had a panicked look on
his face when a man rejected his groping
advances at a pub in the Cotswolds the
alleged victims account recorded in a
police interview was played at the
actors trial he's accused of sex
offenses against four men and denied all
charges
senior Fire Chiefs have warned e-bike
and e-scooter owners not to charge them
overnight after a mother and her two
children died at their home in
Cambridgeshire investigators believe
cheaper unregulated lithium batteries
are causing intense blazes and putting
families at risk a shinki marike reports
this is the moment a lithium battery
explodes engulfing a kitchen in an
Inferno part of a growing number of
fires linked to faulty batteries and
electric bikes and scooters
Dell Williams saw that Danger first hand
he bought a used e-scooter online watch
how it burst into flames at his home to
sound like explosions just happened like
all like you know and that when I've
gone towards I'm opening my door I've
seen orange Flames inside from the other
side of the door it's undescribable
woman it's like it's like when you've
been put in that situation it's it's
like
I'm lucky to be alive
not everyone escapes these incidents
unscape a flat fire this weekend in
Cambridge is believed to have been
sparked by an e-bike left on charge
killing Gemma Germany along with her
children Lily and Oliver
as battery-powered bikes and scooters
become more popular Fire Chiefs are
warning the public to take extra care we
are seeing an increase in these types of
fires and we kind of connect that with
the fact that people own more of these
types of light electric vehicles people
really need to be aware about this type
of incident given the fact that they can
be so ferocious and we've seen the
devastation that this can cause and the
tragedy that comes along with it this
electric bike manufacturer says because
e-bikes are costly with no government
subsidies available people often revert
to cheaper models and batteries I charge
my bag in the house
so I want to make sure that they're safe
you know let alone anybody else I sell
the bike to this battery has been tested
and certified one issue is there's an
influx in cheap batteries being bought
online some from places where
regulations aren't as strict
when batteries overheat consequences can
be catastrophic which is why some
experts are calling for tighter import
controls when a Lithium-Ion battery is
abused for example buying all by being
overcharged overheated crushed
or due to defects or contamination
introduced at the manufacturing stage
they generate huge amounts of gas and
huge amounts of heat with dangers now
being linked to increasingly popular
modes of Transport it's clear more
safety measures and scrutiny are needed
to avoid potentially deadly
circumstances so give my replay Sky News
Elites
now in former mayor Chris Cummins
decided to take a shortcut on his walk
to an East London train station he
didn't expect it would lead to a fight
for survival in fact he was trapped for
five days without food and water as
February temperatures dipped below zero
well today both he and the man who found
him have been speaking disguise Betty
Cockrell
75 years old and stuck like this for
five brutally cold days in February this
tiny passageway is where Chris Cummins
became trapped after trying to take a
shortcut behind his local football club
crawling underneath a pipe he found
himself wedged in with no food or water
and no phone it's incredible that he
survived
I'm told that had I been there for
another two days or more I might have
died
and it was basically rookie Eaton
who was a man who
who saved me
this is Ricky he's gone through there
and he's called through from what we can
gather I think he fell face first he's
the chairman of Red Bridge football club
and was thankfully on site that day
despite cold temperatures stalling play
it was obviously really thirsty and he
was in a poor situation to be fair but
he handled it really well I need the
strengthy son to make it and survive was
really really like oh I can't even
explain yeah
it was a moment the two men couldn't
quite believe he said are you an angel
so like that was quite emotional moment
for us and for him
Chris was taken straight to hospital and
has spent the past few months recovering
he lost a dramatic amount of weight and
is still struggling to get his strength
back but he's incredibly grateful to the
man who found him thank you so much
Ricky for what you've done you saved my
life
and it's a privilege knowing you and I
know my life to you
as for future Journeys home
would you be taking any more shortcuts
anytime soon no no no
well not not that way anyway
Becky Cottrell Sky News East London
well that was Sky News at 10 coming up
we'll take a first look at tomorrow's
newspapers in the Press preview
including this on the front of the Daily
Mail their headline boris's party get
accuser faces his own police probe but
tonight we'll be joined by the chief
leader writer at The Observer Sunday and
the deputy editor at conservative home
Henry Hill
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
well this is Sky News in just a moment
the Press preview a first look at what
is on the front pages first though a
reminder of our top stories this evening
Israeli troops have begun withdrawing
from Janine in the West Bank tonight
winding down at two days of raids which
have killed at least 12 Palestinians in
retaliation Hamas has claimed
responsibility for a ramming attack in
Tel Aviv which injured eight people
31 year old Jamie Barrow has been found
guilty of the murders of a mother and
her two young daughters whose flat he's
set on fire in Nottingham last November
and the Prime Minister says Banks should
not be allowed to close customers
accounts because of their views after
Nigel farage accused coote's Private
Bank of shutting down his account over
his politics
[Music]
well hello they are watching The Press
preview a first look at what is on the
front page is time then to see what's
making the headlines with the chief
leader writer of The Observers on your
soda and the deputy editor of
conservative home Henry Hill and welcome
to both of you so front pages then let
us start with the Daily Mail boris's
party get accuser faces his own police
probe reads the front of the mail amid
reports that a formal probe has been
launched into a birthday drinks bash
held first to Bernard Jenkins wife
the Metro has interviewed the first baby
born out of the NHS who says we must
cherish the Health Service as it
celebrates its 75th anniversary tomorrow
cheaper food on the way as a price war
finally holds up reached the front of
the Daily Express as it looks at
supermarket inflation the front of the
Guardian looks at the government's plans
for global warming with the headline UK
ready to drop an 11.6 billion pound
pledge for a climate fund
the U.S pushes for Wonderland to be the
next NATO Chief reads the headline in
the Daily Telegraph as they report that
Ben Wallace's candidacy has been blocked
the financial times leading with the
bank of England looking at contentious
plans to force more International Banks
to set up subsidiaries in the UK
and the front page of the Daily Mirror
Has what they say is an exclusive
interview with the broadcaster Fiona
Phillips speaking about her own
Alzheimer's diagnosis
and The star looks at the influence of
popular television shows on politics
what a quick reminder by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
listen to our guests so let's head
straight to them and head to Sonia soda
and Henry Hill
um Henry why don't you kick off for us
then uh Daily Mail front page a couple
of partygate probes by the police
they've picked up on one for sabena
Jenkin who we saw in action today of
course what do you make of their
response to this uh to this news
so this is catnip to Boris Johnson's
supporters uh Ben Jenkins was one of the
senior conservatives on the Privileges
committee that delivered that damning
report into Boris Johnson over partygate
and eventually precipitated his
departure from the House of Commons and
now the police are investigating an
allegedly lockdown breaking party uh
held by Sir Bernard to celebrate his
wife's birthday now obviously we don't
want to be judge this investigation we
don't know what's going to happen but
sir Bernard's a p-reappearance that the
Privileges committee has been his first
public outing in a little while he's
been accused of going to ground for
several weeks and and sort of keeping a
low media profile so it definitely
obviously is going to be very
uncomfortable for him personally but it
is also unhelpfully going to give soccer
to Boris Johnson's most committed
supporters who are just on a war path
and out to damage as many people as they
can yeah I mean that's interesting isn't
it that Boris Johnson's team still feel
the need to do that even though he has
exited stage left and the other one of
course is the mingle jingle you know a
conservative HQ party you know who does
that implicate the former candidate for
London mayor who's about to be a peer I
mean there's all sorts of questions that
continue Sonia
yeah absolutely so there were two events
that the Met police have reopened
investigations into one is this party in
uh it's alleged to take place in
Parliament um that Bernard Jenkins was
allegedly at but the second is of course
and this is what the guardian focuses on
um a party in conservative party
headquarters
we already had some photographs from
this party but in the last few weeks an
actual video has emerged
um it's proved extremely controversial
because the former Tory mayoral
candidate Sean Bailey was at that party
and he was awarded a peerage in Boris
Johnson's recent resignation honors
there's also someone there who was
awarded an Obe and um Sean Bailey's
former campaign Chief is now running the
campaign of another Tory
um hopeful to be London mayor so these
are people still very much involved in
conservative politics and the Met police
have said that they're reopening the
investigation into this event as well
that the video provides further Evidence
uh the Met police have apparently got
some criteria that they apply to events
retrospectively from during the pandemic
um it's you know there's got to be sort
of significant evidence of of wrongdoing
flaunting of the rules and they say this
video provides that evidence that they
need what's also interesting is that
they've also said that they have they
aren't yet reopening or opening I should
say
um an investigation into alleged
wrongdoing at checkers by Boris Johnson
and Carrie Johnson they say they they
don't have um enough evidence uh to open
an investigation into that yes all 16 of
them as the guardian points out it also
makes um the front page there too
involving as you said Boris Johnson his
wife Carrie and close friends at Downey
Street and checkers between June 2020
and may 2021
um and Henry while we're on Boris
Johnson
um and in fact the peerage's question
that was something that was put to wish
you soon at the liaison Committee of
Select Committee heads today and he was
asked specifically about his involvement
in that list Boris Johnson's list and
whether there are questions about it
Rishi making quite clear that he passes
the list on without any intervention by
him but do you think we'll get more on
that list to come out because it was all
lost on the day that brought Johnson you
know decided to quit his seat wasn't it
you know do you think we'll see further
investigations into those people
eventually
um yeah it depends on obviously the
evidence that emerges it was the reason
one of the reasons that Boris Johnson's
list was so surprising was that there
were already these question marks over
people like Sean Bailey
um over lockdown rules and so they've
gone forward now it remains to be seen
whether or not new allegations emerge
against anyone or whether any of the
allegations that have already been aired
end up getting taken forward by the
police but really I think the the
extraordinary thing for Richie sunac is
actually that he didn't intervene on
Boris Johnson's resignation honors list
you know as someone who supports the
House of Lords and think it's a valuable
institution and indeed supports the
honor System I think that this was one
last example of Boris Johnson being
extraordinarily Reckless with the
reputation of British institutions I
think it would have been perfectly
reasonable for the prime minister to
hold off on passing on that list it is
only a convention that he passes it on
Boris Johnson is was obviously not prime
minister he can't do anything himself it
is it is all being governed by
convention and conventions can evolve
and instead he's ended up in this really
politically self-inflicted damaging
situation where a couple of days before
the party gate report came in and Boris
Johnson finally blew up Rishi sunak
signed off most of his uh resignation
honest it was a mistake well I mean
Richard you see and I said he was just
following protocol
um and that is what you you have to do
just very quickly Henry we've got you
you know you've got the finger on the
pulse if you like of the Tory membership
how do they feel now about Boris Johnson
and how do they feel Rishi sunak is
doing because it's you know you saw
today on his face on the liaison
committee it's not it's not an easy job
at times and certainly not at the moment
I mean it's definitely not an easy job
so wish you sooner there's a I've really
seen that is not polling well with
conservative party activists in our in
our monthly cabinet League table which
we published this morning he had a
negative score but then so did other
eight other people who either are
members of the cabinet have the right to
attend cabinet so he wasn't alone it's
not all entirely down to Rishi I think
he's kind of the recipient as well of
just deep bone deep frustration by
conservative activists that built up
over the Johnson Premiership and the
trust Premiership I guess we can still
call it that
um about the lack of progress that's
been made on various conservative goals
but absolutely you know he is struggling
as for Boris Johnson he still has his
hardcore of committed supporters but
when we ran releasing questions on Boris
Johnson support for him returning to
Parliament as a Conservative candidate
it is still there but it's going down I
think there's a recognition that his
time has passed okay well more
difficulties for the Prime Minister more
controversy too if we look at the lead
story for the guardian Sonia the
government they say is drawing up plans
to drop the UK's flagship 11.6 billion
pound climate and nature funding pledge
as the prime minister is accused of
betraying populations vulnerable to
Global heating so what is the Pledge and
how significant is this
so this pledge is it's a five-year
pledge five-year commitment that the UK
has made to spend 11.6 billion between
2021 and 2026 is a contribution to a
global fund that is aimed at tackling
climate change around the world
particularly amongst uh less affluent
Nations and protecting nature and
Wildlife for example protecting forestry
now the UK has always been seen as a
global leader on these sorts of
commitments but the guardian is
reporting uh this evening uh news of an
internal memo between government
departments where essentially this memo
sets out the reasons for why this 11.6
billion is going to be difficult to meet
I think it's incredibly worrying and
also massively self-defeating we know
that climate change is increasingly
going to drive uh migration movements
across the globe as more and more people
aren't able to inhabit where they live
anymore as a result to sort of
catastrophic changes in the climate and
you know this is this fund is something
that's aimed at helping to reduce the
impacts of global heating uh worldwide
really but particularly helping less
affluent Nations reduce their carbon
emissions so it's a really really
important initiative and I think for the
UK to renege would be very very worrying
indeed and when you think about it 11.6
billion over five years in the grand
scale of government spending it really
isn't that much
I mean yes the guardian pointing out
that the problem is that
um help for Ukraine Falls within the aid
budget so it's almost impossible to meet
these targets
um and and of course it was a political
some might say decision to cut the aid
budget of the UK Henry
yeah the government cut it from 0.7 to
0.5 of GDP uh on account of the they
they said the enormous pressure on the
public finances and you know ultimately
that's a move there consistently I think
polls well at least with conservative
voters but it does leave them with this
problem this is also just also an
example of classic treasury thinking
right you know you make this big
commitment and then you say that
actually most of you you're going to
spend most of the money in the next
financial period in the next five year
spending round right you'll spend a
little bit of money now but you'll
definitely spend the rest of money later
and then things get tight and the money
gets cut this happens in British
spending and across departments all the
time it's one of the biggest problems
with the way that the British government
handles money in general it's one of the
reasons that hs2 is so expensive is
because everything is shunted into the
future in order to keep the five-year
spending within the treasury's limit so
this is a deeply a deeply unfortunate
development it is it seems like it's
been entirely predictable given that we
know with the government the government
has known what it's spending on Ukraine
it's known that it's the headline budget
you know the fcdo will have known the
financial implications of this so
they've they've sort of seen it coming
but this is not a problem that's unique
to Aid it is not a problem that's unique
to this it is just a symptom of how
badly the treasury manages government
budgets well staying with environmental
issues with financial implications to
the Euless story inside pages of the
Metro uh the London Mercedes Khan lacks
the legal power to expand the capital's
ultra low emission Zone this is the
troy-led councils surrounding London
who've brought this case Sonia
so this is looking shaping up to be a
big legal fight between Sadiq Khan on
the one hand who wants to expand the 12
pounds 50 a day charge for vehicles that
don't meet the standards for the ultra
low emission zones so cars Etc would
have to pay 12 pounds 50 a day and he
wants to extend that zone to the whole
of greater London so it would cover
every London borough and there are a
number of conservative run councils on
the outskirts of London places like
Bromley for example that are challenging
that decision and taking him to court as
to whether he's got the legal power to
do that and I think it remains to be
seen what the outcome of that Court
battle is but the issues at stake are
really really important so on the one
hand you've got the fact that you know
we've got really terrible air pollution
in London we breach kind of legal limits
We Know It's associated
um with with illness and deaths for
example in children with asthma and you
know it's really important that we take
action and quite urgent action to reduce
to improve the quality of air in London
because it really does genuinely cost
lives on the other hand it's very
unpopular
um you know a 12 pound 50 charge for
polluting vehicles and what the
conservative councils are saying is that
some people can't afford to either pay
that charge or switch to a cleaner
vehicle
um you know my feeling is that it's it's
a sort of necessary evil really we've
got to find a way of bringing air
pollution
um in London down
um but you know this is really turning
into a legal fight about what are the
powers of the mayor does he have the
powers to impose us haven't got time for
a full answer but thumbs up or thumbs
down for this policy Henry
I mean I live in central London and use
public transport all the time so from my
perspective it's obviously fine but if
you live in one of the outer boroughs of
London and your life much more resembles
that of a town where you use your car
all the time I can see why this might be
very challenging okay
Henry stay there lots more still to come
including this on the front of the Delhi
Express cheaper food on the way as a
price for the paper suggests finally hot
up
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
and this is for me the best part
I feel like you are flying
first of all when I saw people doing it
I'd never heard of freediving didn't
know what it looked like and I was
amazed by the visuals of people behaving
more like seals and dolphins under the
water and no scuba tanks nothing like
that and I was hooked and then when I
learned about Stephen and Alessia who
were the people in the film and their
connection and what they were trying to
do and I just thought this is an
incredible incredible story well free
diving is basically holding your breaths
and popping your head on the water
that's a bit more complicated than that
well no basically that's freediving but
then we we do the competitive part and
that's going as deep as possible and
pushing human limits I guess and the
dangerous yeah well you can you can
black out because you're holding your
breath for an extended time
um but we have safety divers with us to
minimize the risk and to bring us up if
we black out on the water so alessians
in the movie obviously yeah the the film
follows Alexian Stephen from very early
on like with footage that's 40 years old
we watch them as kids like have a dream
and follow their their goat and follow
those dreams and for almost 20 years
when they come together then
um and meet at the Pinnacle of the
freediving world and they start to work
together and they start to break records
and they decide that they're gonna
do this major freediving
um challenge which is to go down 50
meters and through the arch in Egypt uh
it's a 30 minute 30 meter Arch and at
the other side and so this is that's
kind of what the film is about and their
emotional connection to each other to
the Sea and really trying to push their
limits like the human limit together the
film will be on Netflix on the 19th of
July and there will be a limited release
in London
um on the 14th
[Music]
foreign
welcome back you are watching The Press
preview with me once again the chief
leader writer at the observers on your
soda and the deputy editor at
conservative home Henry Hill welcome
back to both of you lots of news about
supermarkets this week Daily Express
suggests that supermarkets are waging a
wall to drive down prices on food Sonia
yes this is right so apparently
Sainsbury's has announced that it's
reducing
um the prices of a hundred of its sort
of Key Products
um and it says that it thinks that this
is the start of hopefully falling price
inflation which I think news of which
would come as a huge relief to people up
and down the country who are really
struggling with bills as a result of
higher energy prices higher mortgage
rates and rents and of course higher
food prices
um but this is just the sort of first
sign that food prices might eventually
start to fall
um I think we're a long way from knowing
that that's a dead cert so I think we
should be um cautious before doing too
much celebrating yeah
let's move on shall we to the Metro uh
once again news about Thames water after
Sky News break the news uh last week
about their financial difficulties after
the exit of their chief executive Henry
at this time find 3.3 million pounds
after a sewage spill killed more than a
thousand fish and turned Rivers black
and the Metro suggesting the company
deliberately attempted to cover up the
discharge of millions of liters of waste
into waterways close to Gatwick Airport
part of a court hearing and this of
course comes amid great angst amongst
British people about these sewage
discharges that we're seeing
yeah just in case there were sort of
five people left in the country who
thought the Thames water were doing a
good job here we have family a second
story from the past to remind us that in
fact they've been terrible for ages uh
it is remarkable there's not much detail
in the Metro about the uh the
allegations that they misled the
environment agency and tried to cover it
up but when you read the rest of the
story you can see why they might right
apparently when this over school
happened there were no alarms in place
to alert staff that there was an
overspill and that all of this water was
being discharged into the river Network
when they finally did discover that
there was a problem they couldn't get in
touch with the lead engineer because the
lead engineer was awaiting delivery of a
new mobile phone and no one had thought
to give them one in the interim just in
case they needed to do their job it's
it's just absolutely remarkable when you
think about the fact that apparently
this is what causes an awful lot of
these issues you know sometimes there
are you know water companies probably
blaming for everything the this country
is still running largely on Victorian
water infrastructure and we don't build
things like reservoirs and so on but
ultimately so many of these leaks which
cause huge environmental damage and also
prevent people from enjoying Rivers
swimming at the beach and stuff like
that you know really important stuff are
down to basic basic failures of systems
the failure to have an alarm the failure
to make sure you can contact your staff
in good time it's not a surprise that
they tried to like mislead the
environment agency if that's what they
did
um but yeah they've been caught and put
in the dock I mean I mean it sounds
horrifying doesn't it the the Litany of
mistakes that were made there
um the Metro pointing out the company
has 20 previous fines for pollution the
judge in this case ordering bosses to
put in every effort into tidying up the
problem areas but it feels like
Britain's going backwards on this you
know blue flag beaches we celebrated
each and every one over the over over
several decades Sonia and here we are
you know back to square one on this
really
yeah absolutely and you know how
um uh Henry is absolutely right that you
know we've got big big issues with our
infrastructure around water but I think
the way that the industry was privatized
is very much part of that issue so we've
had these privatized um essentially
firms come in that run monopolies over
water in their local area they've had
too few incentives to invest in
upgrading that um that sort of Victorian
infrastructure and um there's been a lot
of private Equity investment and private
Equity investors who've extracted out
profits without making those Investments
and now we've got Thames water a firm
that's loaded up with debt
um you know on the brink of collapse uh
while you've you know it's private
Equity owners have extracted out
um value from the company at the expense
of Bill payers um which is just really
really wrong
so I'm going to stay with you um if you
don't mind for the front of the Daily
Mirror which is shattering news to all
her fans uh Fiona Phillips revealing
that she has Alzheimer's which has
utterly ravaged her family and being
diagnosed a year ago at just the age of
61. so we we certainly spent sent her
you know all our very best don't we
absolutely and I I always think it's so
brave when people um speak out publicly
about a diagnosis to sort of help
um share information about it
um uh Fiona Phillips she's a well-loved
former gmtv presenter she's a columnist
for the mirror very sadly Alzheimer's
took the life of both her mother and her
father and they've both passed away from
the disease and one of the things that
she says in her interview was she you
know feared that she might get the
diagnosis but she thought it might
happen to her when she was around 80 and
obviously she received the diagnosis
relatively Young when she was 61.
um there is some hope in this story
though because she is part of a trial of
a new Alzheimer's drug which doctors and
experts hope will slow the progress of
the disease but it's I mean it's just
such a cruel disease um anyone who's
seen a loved one go through it because
you know it leaves um somebody
physically intact but it removes use
their personality and who they are their
memories and so to watch a loved one go
through it is really really traumatic
and I think it's very brave of her to
talk talk about it openly after it's
clearly um you know had such a big
impact on her family yes my my own
father succumbed after 15 years with
Alzheimer's so I you know I fully
understand and she said her mum her dad
her grandparents and her uncle it just
keeps coming back for us so uh you know
huge sympathy certainly for Fiona
Phillips and her family
let's take a look now at the weather
warm memories wherever you go
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
while the unsettled conditions will
continue this week with the risk of
showers or longer Spells Of Rain Coastal
East Anglia will see overnight heavy
rain and strong winds clearing early on
Wednesday that will leave most places
fine but there'll be a few showers
around they'll develop more widely
through the morning some heavy bright
spells too Breezy for most but a touch
warmer than today
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
[Music]
thank you